entre cantos y ovaciones Colombia y
Venezuela celebraban la reapertura de su
frontera compartida después de siete
años de cierre el acto despertaba
Esperanza ambos costados de los puentes
Simón Bolívar y Francisco de Paula
Santander Pero un mes después las
expectativas se han ido diluyendo para
los habitantes de la zona poco ha
cambiado
quisieras que dejaran pasar siquiera los
carritos Y eso para poder uno ya
facilitar más la pasada porque esta
pasadita aquí siempre es difícil
porque
lo perjudica el trabajo pasar la
mercancía eso Entonces la ayuda de uno
pero nos regresa no lo dejan pasar al
mercancía para acá los gobiernos
aseguran que se está llevando a cabo un
proceso gradual porque el comercio se
hace entre gente entre empresario
entonces en la medida que tú tengas
Claridad de que ese día ese canal es es
seguro o decir la operaciones se están
dando tú va a direccionar más
operaciones por esa vía que por
alternativas las cifras denotan un éxito
moderado según el Ministerio de comercio
colombiano desde la apertura se hicieron
negocios por 2,25 millones de dólares y
pasaron 1552 toneladas de carga de
importaciones y exportaciones
se calcula que 67 camiones de carga han
cruzado por los puentes
muchos siguen siendo los retos Uno de
ellos es combatir el contrabando que
según la cámara de integración económica
venezolano colombiana ha aumentado desde
la reapertura y que en este año ha
generado aproximadamente 900 millones de
dólares